hello and welcome to playstation grenade
it's time for yet another elusive target
elusive target 23 the paparazzo here in
paradise this is a pretty easy one
surprisingly what you're going to do is
start off in the AV unit that's on the
second floor and take your time you have
so much time to do this one it's quite
easy as soon as you have control over
your character just back up hide behind
these little blocks take out your pistol
and depending on your end take out the
camera now you know me I always forget
about photography I always forget about
the video cameras so it's important that
we get rid of those early next make it
round here to where we did the first one
to remember the forger all those months
ago anyway in this next room there are
two guys we need to take out if you're
as quick as I am at this point easily
you can do it now so do both but if
you're a little bit behind don't worry
the opportune moment is when the ear V
chap across the room goes back outside
so we'll wait for that now once he steps
out take down the first chap member
don't snap the neck I did it again I
snap the neck of my first run hat is
restart and this next chap subview him
too right oh I recommend moving him
because again on one of my other
playthrough i accidentally snaps your
neck after i took out the target so i
definitely recommend just shifting him
out the way just burn out right up what
we going to do you're going to use your
pistol and you're going to take out this
speaker thing like the lord is thinking
speaker and it's going to crash down on
the paparazzo we're trying to take out
the problem is we don't know who the
paparazzo is but if you look at that
gentleman just there where I'm aiming
he's got a hat on we know he's a
security guard well luckily we're
looking for a chat with a pork pie hat
on and once we see him we know to time
our attack towards him so it's a little
bit of waiting now but don't worry
nobody can enter this room so don't
worry about the guards on the far side
or the ones a book no one enters this
room we don't have to tidy up after
ourselves we just wait yes right okay
he's coming now can you see he got to
the pot pie hat on he looks like
out of breaking bad or something and
about ten paces behind him is his
security guard so the plan is we wait
until he walked underneath our feet by
the way I'm in between where the room
ends and the assaulter under a balcony
starts once he gets underneath our feet
we're going to aim at the speaker so
he's under me now one two three four
five shoot ok so just over five sessions
between your kitchen perfectly if you
mess it up and I did the first time just
pause your game and restart there's
nothing wrong with that if you're new to
this you can reach that target all the
time I have a video to help you out
anyway we're on our way out I want to
show you this be careful when you're
running because there are cameras
everywhere so please follow these
footsteps we're going back to where we
first started and there should be some
stairs just to the right hand side
nobody cares that you here so don't
worry about anyone now not even this
gent here and downstairs the cook don't
care either so we can run openly through
the basement without ever being
challenged that's what we're going to do
simple as this once you're out of here
turn right and take a right again look
they're not bothered even head chef he's
not bothered and as long as you press
the button at the right time you can get
out of the mission much quicker than I
can anyway that's it easy Sal assassin
if it has helped please do as a favor
and give us a like and think about
subscribing if you don't know about
restarting these elusive target I will
link a video on the left here thanks for
your time I'll see you soon
you